we're here to talk about a topic that's
something the two of us are incredibly
passionate about it's something that we
spend most of our days thinking about
pretty sure Niall dreams about it most
nights it's a topic that's especially
timely today and that is snowflake
optimization
so my name is Ian and this is Niall we
are the founders of a company called
select we provide software that helps
users lower their snowflakes Bend and
optimize their usage
through doing this we've worked with
nearly 30 companies 30 different
companies using snowflake in a variety
of different ways and
um today we're really excited to share
all the different things we've learned
through that process and things we wish
we knew when we were starting out a few
years ago
before we kick things off we want to set
some contacts so last year marked the
end of the longest Bull Run in history
and that was a period where companies
were really focused on growth and maybe
less concerned with how much it was
costing to achieve that growth
if we Flash Forward to today that is
flipped and now most teams or
departments within companies are being
asked to more carefully scrutinize their
spend and potentially lower that spend
if we look at the data team after human
costs the biggest cost center is
typically the data warehouse so that'll
drive most of their SAS spend so we have
now is data teams that are being asked
more carefully monitor understand and
lower the spend within their warehouse
and correspondingly try and write more
performance SQL
so today's talk will focus solely on
snowflake snowflake is a market leader
in the data Cloud space and they have
lots of different cost and performance
levers available which we believe allows
you to run one of the most cost
effective data warehouses
with that said if you're not using
snowflake a lot of the principles we'll
talk talk about today will apply to most
of the modern data warehouses that are
out there
snowflake optimization is a long topic
and Scott respectfully declined our
request to give a four-hour lecture so
we're going to do the best we can in the
next 30 minutes or so I think we'll have
a couple minutes at the end for
questions but I do want to call out that
there is a official office hours
so we'll be there immediately after this
talk if people want to go deeper into
any of the things that we discussed I
also want to mention that we will post
our slides that we use for this talk on
our website probably later today
so don't worry about if you miss
anything we're going to be posting links
uh and code Snippets throughout so those
all be available online later
and then yeah lastly we're both going to
be here until Friday
um so if you want to chat with us about
any of this stuff at any point uh I
think we plan to wear these t-shirts
every day we have some extras don't
worry it won't be too smelly
um yeah all right so before we dive into
the different optimization strategies
we'll do a quick overview of snowflakes
architecture the one thing I do want to
call out is snowflake is more than data
warehouse It's a full-on data Cloud but
today we're just focusing on the data
warehousing core product that most
customers use
so snowflakes architecture
a big part of snowflake's popularity
came from the fact that they have these
three different layers Each of which
scale independently
so that first layer is cloud services so
this will be the entry point for every
interaction you have with snowflake it
will do things like check authentication
and access control for the data it does
a very important step called query
optimization where it actually figures
out what data does your query need to
access and what's the best way to
perform that query we're going to talk a
lot about that and it does other things
like transaction and infrastructure
management and has a giant Global result
cache which is great for performance
second layer is compute so this is where
the actual query execution happens and
snowflake has this interesting concept
of virtual warehouses which will spend a
lot of time on today
what they allow customers to do is
create different warehouses or compute
clusters that can handle different
workloads or different use cases and
customers can have those warehouses or
configure those warehouses with
different settings based on their needs
the final layer is storage so snowflake
runs on different Cloud providers
depending on what cloud provider you use
your tables will be stored in the
storage service from that cloud so for
an example if you're using Amazon your
tables would be stored in Amazon's S3
service
to tile this together it's helpful to
study the life cycle of a query in
Snowflake so if we look at the top left
you have an analyst that's way too
excited who's about to submit a query to
snowflake
so as mentioned as soon as that query
gets submitted the first entry point is
cloud services so after cloud services
checks do they are they authenticated do
they have the right access taxes these
tables they would then check the result
cache so the cloud services layer has a
result cache where it stores the results
of previously executed queries so if
they're the same it doesn't need a
repeat all that query execution it can
really quickly fetch that result which
is great for this example we'll pretend
that this query hasn't been executed
before so it has to skip the result
cache go on to things like query
optimization check for other conflicting
transactions and decide which Warehouse
to run on
that brings us to the compute layer so
in the compute layer
the servers will read from remote
storage so they'll fetch the data they
need to produce the results of your
query perform all those computations and
then return those back to cloud services
uh to store and back to the client
from a cost standpoint what we typically
see with the customers we work with is
that this compute layer makes up
typically about 90 percent of what
people will spend in Snowflake so that's
really where we want to focus most of
our time today there are things you can
do as well to reduce your spend or
optimize usage on the storage and cloud
services layer but we're really going to
focus heavily on the compute side if you
want to chat about those other ones
let's connect after
all right I'm now going to turn it over
to Niall who's going to talk about uh
best practices when it comes to setting
up your virtual warehouses
great
okay so the first thing that we need to
understand is snowflakes billing model
um and then once we've done that we're
going to talk through optimal virtual
Warehouse configuration and then also
the importance of Warehouse
consolidation as well
so snowflake uses usage-based pricing
which means that you're only paying for
the resources which are active at any
given time
and it also uses per second billing
snowflake has a currency called credits
which are between two and four dollars
depending on your snowflake Edition
and each Warehouse size consumes a
different number of credits per hour so
the smallest Warehouse in Snowflake is
the extra small that's one credit per
hour as small as two and so on
and there's a minimum of 60 seconds
build each time a warehouse is resumed
so what's a virtual Warehouse um a
visual Warehouse is an abstraction over
the compute instances that your
snowflake account is running on top of
so for AWS that's ec2 for Google Cloud
platform that's compute engine
um each node that forms a virtual
Warehouse is roughly kind of equals or
threads 16 gigabytes of RAM and it has a
local SSD as well the exact specs vary
between Cloud platform but that's the
rough kind of level
stuff like uses these t-shirt sizes to
designate the the resources available to
each Warehouse size and they go all the
way from an extra small to a 6xl and
each size represents double the
resources available but also double the
cost as well
and increasing the warehouse size is
called scaling up so that means that the
query has more and more resources
available to run on top of which should
give it more performance
we also have something called
multi-cluster warehouses and these are
available in Enterprise snowflake
editions and above and these really are
best used for increased query volumes so
not necessarily more complex queries or
larger data volumes but just where the
number of queries increases throughout
the day multi-cluster warehouses can be
used to meet that demand in a
cost-effective way and snowflake will
also scale those instances in when
they're no longer being used
so here's how we recommend that you
configure virtual warehouses it's always
good to start with the cheapest option
which is an extra small and single
cluster Warehouse
there's a setting called the max cluster
count which shows how many clusters
snowflake can spin up to maximum to meet
that meet that load and whenever you see
queuing you can increase that Max
cluster count or last note like to scale
up to meet that demand
there's also a setting called also
suspend and so this is used so that
snowflake measures how long it's been
since a crew is running and once it
exceeds this threshold snowflake will
automatically suspend the warehouse
so by default snowflake actually sets
this to 10 minutes for any warehouses
that you create through the UI we
recommend setting it to 60 seconds
pretty much always and that's going to
give you a really good balance of
efficiency and cost as well
the next thing that we recommend
changing from the default is the query
timeout so by default snowflake will
cancel Cruise after two days of
execution but most of the time if a crew
is running that long it probably should
be so we recommend reducing that to a
between kind of two or four hours
obviously that will vary on the
warehouse the virtual Warehouse that
you're using because some kind of
transformation workloads maybe they take
longer but equally bi queries should
probably take a lot less time
and finally we recommend using resource
monitors so resource monitors are a
relatively new snowflake feature in the
last year which allows you to be alerted
either when your usage exceeds a certain
threshold or you can set an alert based
on exceeding Like a Rolling average of
the past few days which is a great way
of being alerted on usage spikes without
having to say what anomalous usage is
and when it comes to Warehouse sizing
it's really important to set that based
on the workload that's running on the
warehouse
so for workloads which can tolerate some
queuing for example data loading or
transformation anything which isn't user
facing the best way to configure that
warehouse is to have some queuing which
seems counter-intuitive but what it
means is that the warehouse is being
really well utilized so whenever the
warehouse is being built for it's always
being used at full capacity
um when it comes to data transformation
workloads I'll give an example for DBT
but this applies to other tools as well
rather than increasing the warehouse
size for every single transformation
when it gets too slow actually if you
just find the kind of slowest couple of
workloads within that transformation
process and just just put those on a
larger Warehouse you'll get way more
cost effective utilization and because
some queries just don't scale that well
on a bigger Warehouse which I'll show
next so by just putting those slower
more complex screens on that bigger
Warehouse you'll get much faster
runtimes at the best possible costs
so this is how we like to kind of
visualize the effects of Warehouse size
on query execution time
most queries will perform great on an
extra small so this is really just for
kind of those big data transformation
queries that you run
um and what you'll see is that crew is
improving speed roughly double as the
warehouse size increases up to a certain
point and that's because queries can
distribute well across more resources so
more CPU more RAM that we mentioned
before up to a certain point at which
snowflake will just go actually this
query can't run any faster across any
more cores like it can't be parallelized
any better at which point the query
speed is going to remain the same but
the cost is going to go up right because
the warehouse size is even bigger
um and so the best way to find The Sweet
Spot is to increase the warehouse size
once at a time observe the query time
half and then once you see that starting
to tail off actually just go back down
one Warehouse size and that's going to
give you really good cost and
performance
okay and the final thing on this
Warehouse configuration station is
consolidation
so something that we see quite a lot is
organizations who have a lot of virtual
warehouses and it makes sense because
um it's not like bills per Warehouse as
I mentioned before and actually in the
snowflake UI that's how you can
visualize costs at this per Warehouse
level so to understand costs by team by
project it's a good place to start
the downside of using so many warehouses
is that you end up with much less
efficient usage of that resource so as I
mentioned before snowflake always
charges you for the first 60 seconds of
a warehouse running and if you have lots
of warehouses which may be only process
a query every 30 seconds or a few
minutes you can end up paying for a lot
of completely unused Warehouse active
time
so instead we recommend creating
warehouses by workload requirements so
not by domain so for example we've got
on the bottom here kind of DBT we've got
a warehouse for each size which maybe
the models are configured individually
to run on and then we have some
observability tools which are also all
showing the same warehouse because they
have the same kind of requirements and
likewise maybe we have a user-facing
warehouse where we need to make sure
that there's no queuing the crews are
really fast that can all go on one
Warehouse
the downside of this approach is that
we've lost this immediate granularity of
usage observation that you can get in
snowflakes UI but we'll talk a little
bit later about a package that we've
made which uses query cost attribution
which then allows you to roll up costs
by any Dimension that you that you care
about so maybe that's by user or by
something else so even though you've got
these Consolidated warehouses you can
still get really granular cost reporting
even more so than at the warehouse level
okay let's move on to optimizing
performance
um and to start with we're going to talk
through pruning and clustering and then
Ian's going to talk a bit about career
design but pruning and clustering are
really important to understand first
so there are three topics I'm going to I
want to go through the first is micro
partitions which is snowflakes table
format
next is pruning and then finally the
thing that enables pruning which is
clustering
so snowflake uses its own proprietary
closed source file format which is
called a micro partition
and these are just stored in the cloud
provider your snowflake account runs on
again it's what's called a hybrid
columnar format which means that each
contains batches of rows so the
snowflake can only retrieve the micro
partitions that are relevant to the
query that you're running
but also within each micro partition
snowflake can retrieve just the columns
that you're selecting as well and that's
really just all about reducing the
amount of data which has to be scanned
from remote storage which is a really
costly operation in Computing
the other thing worth knowing is that
micro partitions are immutable so they
can't be edited once they've been
created instead snowflake has to delete
and recreate them and that's why
snowflake recommends against lots and
lots of small DML operations in a table
so it's good to avoid doing lots and
lots of inserts and lots of updates and
instead you want to kind of batch those
together to get the best performance and
costs
snowflake records metadata for micro
partitions
um and the most important one to
understand for the next topic which is
pruning is this minimum and maximum
value that snowflake records for each
column
and this is how it can discard micro
partitions which it knows aren't
relevant to the query and this metadata
is stored in the cloud services layer
that Ian mentioned earlier and so that
means that it's available to snowflake
before it even starts processing your
query snowflake can identify which micro
partitions are needed
so recruiting this really is the secret
to every fast query success
we've got an example query here which is
selecting from this orders table for all
records after August 2022. and we can
see here in this kind of illustration
there are three rows for micro partition
and reality there will be tens of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
per micro partition
um but in this example we can see that
in this creator that column each micro
partition has only got a very narrow
range of values for that created that
column and because snowflake is stored
at the minimum and maximum value in its
metadata layer when it sees this query
and that we only want records after this
date it can immediately just discard
most of the micro partitions in the
table because it knows that they're just
not relevant to answering the query
and you can identify pruning using
snowflakes Query profile
so on the right hand side here in this
little window at the bottom we've got
two stats which are important to know so
the first is partition scanned and the
second is partitions total
partitions total represents the total
number of micro partitions which are
used by tables that you've queried from
and partitions scanned is the ones that
have actually been retrieved so we want
that partition scan number to be as low
as possible and wherever that scan
number is really high that shows that
we're not getting good pruning
performance which usually shows that
there's an opportunity to do some
optimization
so before we saw this orders table which
has got a really narrow range of created
app values between each micro partition
and that's called This is called
clustering right so clustering describes
the distribution of data across a
table's micro partitions and a column is
described to be well clustered when we
have that state so only a really narrow
range of values per micro partition
and as a result snowflake can prune
really well when we apply a filter on
that column
so how do we get into this
well-clustered state
there are kind of three ways that we
like to categorize these the first is
natural clustering this is by far the
best because you don't have to do
anything
um and this occurs just because records
are naturally inserted into a table with
a column which represents when they're
loaded so for example with the orders
table again as new orders are generated
and etl'd into that table we get new
micro positions that are created which
have all got really new created app
values which have all got a really tight
range and that's great because if we
query based on a created that column
we're going to get really good pruning
performance without doing anything
but sometimes the natural order of the
columns the natural order of the
insertion doesn't actually match the
usage pattern so
let's say we have a few teams who all
crew from that orders table but they
only care about a specific store
um if they're querying by store ID all
of a sudden we can't really prune that
table very well because it's not well
clustered on that column
so instead we can use the automatic
clustering service this is provided by
snowflake as a kind of fully serverless
and managed solution for changing the
clustering of a table to match a
specific column or a couple of columns
that you need
um so you can enable this and snowflake
will just in the background delete and
recreate those micro partitions to
Cluster them against the key that you
specify
the downside is that it comes at a cost
so whenever you use the automatic
clustering service it's really important
to both monitor the performance of the
queries which are hitting the table but
also the cost of running that automatic
clustering Service as well to decide if
it's worth it
and then finally we have this manual
sourcing option
so in the same way that naturally
clustered tables really are just sorted
by the clustered column we can do that
ourselves manually so if you run a
create or replace table as a select from
that very same table ordered by the
column that you want to Cluster by so I
feel like it's just going to replace
that table with a sorted version of
itself which leads you kind of in the
same state as the natural clustering
that I mentioned before so if you have a
table which is either static or like
rarely updated this is the most cost
effective way to get to a well-clustered
state
the downside of manual sorting is that
if any DML operations occur to the table
while you're performing this create or
replace operation you can actually lose
those DM DML operations the snowflake
replaces at the end of the query so this
is really only for places where a table
is not being updated
so how do we find good candidates for
clustering
um really it just comes down to columns
which are used in where Clauses and also
joint conditions which anal mentioned in
a bit but the column should have a large
enough number of distinct values that
snowflake is able to discard columns
that aren't needed so if you choose a
column which has only got two different
values like a true or a false and they
represent maybe like 50 of the values in
the table each
and you filter on that snowflake at most
is going to be able to discard half the
micro partitions If instead you use
something like a timestamp that we
mentioned before you'll see much better
pruning performance because snowflake
can discard more micro partitions
and you can use Query history access
history as well as just your kind of own
understanding and knowledge of the data
to understand what a good column is to
Cluster by
okay let's go to crew design
sweet thank you yeah so um Niles laid
down some Good Foundations on how to
structure your tables in a way that you
can achieve proving pruning and then how
you can achieve the different methods
you can use to Cluster what I want to
talk about next is once you've done all
that what are different ways you can
design your queries to ensure they're
running efficiently
before I do that I want to share two
things that I'd want everyone to
consider before they go down go down
this route
so the first is understanding what the
expected Roi is the last thing we want
is for practitioners to go spend hours
or days tuning queries or changing
configurations if the payback won't be
there for the business so that's an
important thing to upfront to understand
upfront make sure whatever optimization
effort you're embarking on is going to
provide the value relative to the time
you'll spend
the next thing when it comes to queries
is seeing if you can reduce the
frequency so a common thing that we see
is you may have a dashboard that
contains a bunch of queries that
dashboard is scheduled to run every hour
and then correspondingly the data models
that populate that table are also
scheduled to run every hour that can add
up so it's worth scrutinizing are people
actually looking at this every hour
doesn't need to be run that frequently
when you look at the cost side of that
it can save you can save a lot of money
just by changing the frequency so if you
think about a data model that costs ten
thousand dollars a year because it's
running it's updating every hour just by
switching that to run once per day you
can drop up to 95 of those costs
cool let's move on to some of the things
you can do once you've checked check
those boxes on how you can actually make
your queries run faster
so if there's one tip I want everyone to
remember from today which applies to any
modern data warehouse is this old
database adage which says the fastest
way to process data is to not process
data
so we spent a lot of time talking about
query pruning and clustering for this
exact reason
um snow the snowflake Optimizer does an
amazing job of taking the different
filters you put in your query and then
figuring out which my competitions
actually need to be read so we showed an
example earlier where we selected from a
where uh we filtered on an order date
with a constant snowflake handles that
great they also will handle more complex
scenarios where if you where you
calculate a value you want to filter on
through a CT or a sub query so most of
the time this this just works but there
are certain scenarios where it can fail
some examples of that are if you apply a
function on the predicate in your filter
or if you do a type conversion another
interesting thing that can happen is
your table can get degraded clustering
health so those those micro partitions
don't have a narrow range of data
anymore an example of where that can
happen is um like I'm wearing a whoop
band so this uh emits event data I don't
know if Loop is using uh snowflake but
it emits data up into some data
warehouse so normally that data arrives
um the day it's emitted but there could
be scenarios where my device goes
offline for a week and then it comes
back on and now all of a sudden we have
all of this old data being mixed with
new data and that could hurt your
clustering health because those micro
partitions now have a mix of old and new
data so whenever you have a query that's
taking a long time to run or it's
expensive it's worth taking a look at
the Query profile that that Nile showed
or the query history to make sure that
you're getting the pruning you expect
because there are those scenarios where
it may not be optimal
the other recommendation to process less
data is to use incremental
materializations so in today's age it's
very common for people to do data
transformations in the warehouse because
it's easy a common pattern is just to
create a data model that just
reprocesses all the data every time it
runs most of the time this is fine but
for larger data sets that can get really
expensive so we encourage for those more
complex models you consider incremental
materializations where you only process
the new records that haven't been
processed yet and don't kind of waste
all that compute reprocessing the same
data over and over
the next tip is about another way in
which you can enable pruning in
Snowflake which is a really interesting
one
so the examples we showed before are
something that's called Static pruning
so when we did when Nyle showed that
example on the orders table where you
had a where order date greater than date
that's something snowflake can figure
out up front in the cloud services layer
when it's deciding what micro partitions
need to be read for your query
another way you can do this is through
an optimization snowflake has built in
called join filtering and what happens
here is when you have two tables
snowflake can look at the values in one
of the tables and then use that to push
down to the other table to decide oh
these values are in this table we
actually only need these certain micro
partitions from this other table
so a good example of where this applies
is in merges so again let's imagine we
have a big orders table that maybe has
billions of Records
we have a small subset of those orders
that we want to update
this orders table has a random unique
key we'll call it order key and the
table is not clustered by this key
because it's random so if I were to
write this merge statement just using
that order key when we go to update that
table snowflake would do a full table
scan because it has to search all the
micro partitions across those billions
of Records to find those orders that we
want to update
um but we may know that we have this
other column called order date that the
table is well clustered by maybe because
of that natural clustering that Nile
described
so if we add if we just add in an
additional join predicate on that well
clustered column that can actually
enable pruning because of that
phenomenon I described where it can say
oh what are all the order dates in this
small orders temp table
let's remove all the micro micro
partitions from that big table which
doesn't contain any of those dates
so this is a really important one
whenever you have joins and if you have
a if you have a well-clustered column
that's not in that join condition and it
doesn't affect the output it's great to
add those in and you'll get much better
results
the next thing I want to talk about is
ctes which is always a Hot Topic in the
optimization space
um
so we talked about query pruning before
which essentially gets rid of micro
partitions that you don't need to read
column pruning is a similar a similar
thing the end goal is to read less data
this time column pruning is removing
unnecessary columns that we don't need
to read from a particular micro
partition
so if we look at the example I have on
the bottom left I have this CTE called
active users where I'm selecting all
this all the columns from this user's
model
um
if I reference that CTE later and I only
select two columns snowflake well the
snowflake Optimizer will recognize that
and it will only read two of The Columns
from that table so it'll avoid scanning
potentially hundreds of other columns we
don't need so that's what column pruning
is most of the time this works but there
can be scenarios where this breaks down
so two examples of that are if the ctes
reference more than once or if the CTE
is used in a join
so because of that we recommend just as
a general practice always explicitly
list out the columns when you're
defining a CTE so you can assure you're
always getting that column pruning
optimization
and the last one I want to talk about is
filtering early
so again the snowflake Optimizer most of
the time does a great job of figuring
out the most efficient way to execute
your query and one of those things it
does is with Filter operations so if you
have a where statement at the end of
your query and that can be moved up as
early as possible in the operation
snowflake will do that automatically for
you but sometimes it can't do this so an
example is this query on the right where
we have a couple joints and then we have
a qualify statement at the very end this
qualify statement will actually run
after all that expansive join has been
done against those data sets and then we
may end up discarding half the records
so if you look closely this qualify
statement actually just operates on one
of the tables so the most effective way
to write this query would actually be to
push that up into a CTE before the joins
where you filter out all those rows on
that table using that same qualify
statement and then when the joins happen
they're working on much less data which
will make your query faster so whenever
possible help snowflake out push your
make your filters as early as possible
so you can avoid processing as much data
great as we wrap up we want to leave you
with some final suggestions and
resources so if you're looking to get
started with better understanding your
your snowflake usage we've open sourced
a package that called DBT snowflake
monitoring that helps you understand
cost drivers and one of the most useful
things it does which Nile hinted at
earlier is we have a query cost
attribution model in there so you can
use that to identify within a virtual
Warehouse what are the most expensive
queries or workloads that are driving my
costs and where should I focus my time
from there you can create dashboards to
monitor your costs uh identify notify
your team if there's a big spike and
then create lightweight rituals like a
monthly or quarterly review to keep tabs
in your costs and decide hey maybe we
should spend a bit of time this Sprint
um optimizing one of these workloads
and then the last thing I want to call
out is that for anyone looking to
immediately lower their snowflake costs
or better under the understand their
spend we do have a SAS product that's
currently available in Early Access so
if anyone's interested happy to chat
more about that it does a lot of the
things we talked about today
um so yeah uh feel free to chat with us
at any point or you can send us an email
hello select.dev we'd love to we'd love
to talk
and with that
um yeah I just want to say thanks so
much for listening
[Music]